We worked for him but we are also
paying the price the idea was that when
he pretended to be us, that
is the agreement I had with the
lady but unfortunately this
incident happened so things got
complicated for
me. Tell me why
we have always worked  two in the
trailer
cooking and having an audience
tell me a little about you these are from
colombia when you arrived in las vegas and
more or less how much you have with this
project of me more than che I arrived in
las vegas in the year 2000 1918 2018
2018 there is  that here and shortly after
she arrived she will arrive in 2019 at the beginning of the year in
2019 well
the idea came from me more
because well they were already working like
in a trailer she also brings Mexican food
there I was also
working and well it came to us like like
the restlessness, that is, why not have
our own business because in
Colombia there are very tasty foods that are very
tasty, we couldn't find them here
and it can even come out of the
ordinary.  traditional and going out of
mass against
me was necessary, so that also prompted us
as a welcome among
all Colombians. At the beginning it was more
towards Colombian food and when
the cover thing happened we had to
close
reinvent ourselves again
we used Mexican food friends
so tell me  mimas kitchen began
then in the year 2019 and more or less
that they sell that they sold
hamburgers hot dogs and patacon
traditional pisao from the Colombian coast of
the empanadas the arepas the potatoes or the
phrases that are accompanied with their
sausages and all those meats
that were built
The curritos quesadillas were the most
basic that we could have, but a
small trailer we cannot extend
an extension of a lot of food either,
and even for you, what did
that name mean and where did that name come from?
it was where we lived we had no where else
and the name mimas arose from my name
mo miguel
juan miguel león and more
now if they can find me this one that
happened then when the
fire happened and more or less this one when
they found out and their reaction well
normally I close my business and
come home every day I arrive at  my
house and we were inside the house
when her gentlemen
from the tire shop where I stopped the trailer
called me and said trailers are
fuming so we left and I'm going
there we called the numbers and left
when we got to the beach it was
putting on fire I opened it because from the
outside nothing could be seen it would be one more no
fire
April attracts the many fires on
the left side brings it 81 I met
distinguished those who already had the
star while I tried to turn it off
but it was enough the game was not  you can
control it
so the firefighters arrived here and they
were the ones who ended the fire and there
was nothing else to do the next day
we grabbed the trail and
we have it because there are u below  na police station
because in the conditions it has it
cannot continue to function
so this causes you to
close me more than simply for
now well
2 well
how can we put a function on it
and they are very strict with their
enormous distribution rules so to put
the police station to work  It moves in the conditions
that I think are the safest to
buy a new one
so for now we don't have the money
to buy it and well at this moment
we are already working as employees we are
normally starting to go to work
again as employees well the idea is to
collect money well  pay if we
manage to settle debts
and pay off that trailer and the others can
start to see if we start to save
normally to buy one
and for you, that is, all this that you
lived through and it was at times a
very good moment, you
lived after the comic they reinvented themselves and
Now the fire is over,
what comes to mind, how do you feel?
Well, we feel very
excited.  Courage,
well, we did have a fall, quite a hard emotional blow,
but which we want to throw
for people
jumping and this incident is going to affect us
less, it is going to touch our dreams, because
we have mania and what we want
for ourselves
can continue.  go ahead and we have to
do something to continue it is very encouraging for
us also to know the reaction
of the people because of the clients we
had from the Hispanic community in
general because we announced
that we are closing and we inform them that
we are no longer going to receive orders anymore  We
are not going to be open to the
public because it was logical to advertise and
close our pages
and see if we can do it in the
future it will take time, so we
did not want to generate expectations like
in people when, for example, when
we look with our mobile we always
I wrote they called us when they are going to open
and we don't expect it
to be soon but this time we saw it
with  that it was not going to be so soon, so it was
better to notify the people and well, they
manifested themselves in a way that we
actually no longer
imagined.  with
an economic contribution because it is what
we are really needing
then, well, that encouraged us to think that
yes, that is, anything can happen and we
cannot stay there, we have to undertake
it anyway, because we also started
with very little,
we had the push  from friendly
hands from generous hands that helped us
so it is always possible and they
have also felt the support of the other
Colombian businesses that no one here in
Las Vegas like, look, see, the
Lord has half made the contribution,
what does the company expect?  lady of realization
and her husband have been very charitable today
we are going to extend this mother they have
told me anything they need
count on us  We
can help them. It has been quite
gratifying to feel that
support from them and from the
community, since they visited our
establishment.
That has been very encouraging for us.
Something else they want to tell or say to the
Hispanic community and that the  You are seeing the
entire community of the networks that
is supporting you, that they made this
golf page and that right now I think there are
four more like Castilla reaching
five.
this
weekend thursday and friday also camilo
is a person who also had a
business two years ago he planted but he wants to
reopen his page to be receiving
orders thursday and friday he
sold colombian style hot dogs
so he wants to offer again to
the community for the  sale of these two
days you can give intonation contribution to
us
so in that we will be in that
Thursday and Friday  It is and Goñi's account is
also an initiative of the
Colom group in wineries and that was really a
very, very great display of their affection for
their solidarity and well, it is nothing for
us, all of this is well
, the affection of the people helps us a
lot.
that we can continue to
receive these donations and it is very, very
encouraging that we can also reach
the goal of the Colombian groups.
We want to thank them because they have given
great support
to the Oscar de Robinson group and that
they are like
[  Music]
of a light and a help not only for
us but them london were the ones
who took the initiative of the group and
went to our try they made a
video it was published on social networks
and thanks to them many people
listened to us they have guided us messages not  Only
from here, from Colombia, we have also
had people who have supported us
morally and that is very encouraging for
us and we want to thank you
for that kind gesture.  ito that they have
had with us and tell them that
God blesses them and that despite the
difficulties in life or
anything else that one believes, they
can stop it as long as they are firm
believing in God and that one will
get up again  and go ahead
thank you very much for your time here I am going
to pay it is